good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight in the past 10 days two
separate teenage boys have committed
horrifying massacres in public places
on may 14 18 year old peyton gendron
murdered 10 shoppers in a grocery store
in buffalo and then yesterday 18 year
old salvador ramos killed 19 small
children and two teachers at an
elementary school in texas
both gendryn and ramos were very
obviously mentally ill the people around
them knew that both killers had told
other people they planned to commit a
mass shooting and then they did
so what can we learn from this well the
first most obvious answer is that the
system in place didn't work gendron's
teacher sent him to a mental hospital
for evaluation they knew he was a threat
they tried their best he committed a
massacre anyway
so we know for a fact that what we're
doing isn't working but we should also
be honest enough to acknowledge that
it's very hard to know what to do
instead
despite what you may have heard the
problem isn't that we don't care enough
there's not a person in this country who
is not horrified by the sight of
murdered children it's the worst thing
and everybody thinks that
the problem is that the human mind is
much more complex and harder to control
than we like to admit a person who is
intent on committing violence is very
hard to stop under any circumstances an
act of congress isn't going to do it
neither will gun control there are more
guns in this country than there are
people there always have been
however you feel about that fact you can
acknowledge that we will never get rid
of all of those guns the constitution
prohibits that and you would set off a
civil war if you tried to do it
so gun control whether you find the
slogans appealing or not will not stop
the next patron gendron or salvador
ramos and every rational person knows it
the only way to stop these killings is
to figure out why american society is
producing so many violent young men
there is a reason they are acting this
way what is that reason
and it's not just mass shooters by the
way the ones you see on television it's
gang bangers and carjackers and armed
robbers and indiscriminate haters who
push strangers in front of subway trains
we have a lot of people like that in
this country all of a sudden more than
you like to think about
why are they acting this way
that's the only question that matters
of course it's the only question our
leaders hate to address because there's
nothing in it for them
last night the president united states
went on television just hours after 19
small children had been murdered
he didn't do that to uplift or unite the
country which was already united in its
sorrow
instead he took the opportunity to once
again harangue anyone who didn't vote
for him and he did it as always with a
series of stale talking points left over
from the 1980s it was a shameful display
here's part of it
as a nation we have to ask when in god's
name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
when in god's name
we do we all know in our gut needs to be
done
what in god's name do you need a solvent
for except to kill someone
deer aren't running through the
forest with kevlar vests on for god's
sake
is just sick
and the gun manufacturers have spent two
decades aggressively marking assault
weapons which make them the most in
largest profit
for god's sake we have to have the
courage to stand up to the industry
children are dying because the gun lobby
is profiting
it's disgusting he would say something
like that it's also untrue it's mindless
the new york times by the way said the
same thing within hours of the shooting
the gun lobby
please the nra declared bankruptcy last
year the nra is a husk
in 2021 for example the tech company
spent more than 70 million dollars
lobbying congress big pharma spent 92
million lobbying congress in the first
quarter of 2021 alone the nra spent just
2.2 million total lobbying in all of
2020 a presidential election year
spare us
whatever the problem is it's not the gun
lobby
they're not the reason those children
were murdered yesterday it's insulting
and divisive and stupid this is too
serious a moment for nonsense like that
stop
but over at msnbc they were completely
convinced watch
and again
as president biden said i thought he did
an extraordinary job last night
and i really do i feel sorry for those
who actually saw that
and were actually forced
to say something really about him after
he did it i mean that that's how they
make their money
it really
makes me really sad for them
that they have that dark of a soul that
they're that twisted
oh joe scarborough said in naughty word
on tv this must be serious
and in fact it is very serious in fact
it's too serious for tired partisan
platitudes from the reagan era update
your profile
politicians offering solutions to the
tragedy in the end serve only to make
their political party more powerful
should be
excluded from this conversation it is
too important they are speaking in bad
faith obviously and so is anyone whose
bodyguards carry extended magazines or
other so-called weapons of war
they're hypocrites they have no standing
get back to us when you follow your own
demands
anyone on tv who's been accused of a
crime should also take this opportunity
to be very quiet no wants a moral
lecture from you
but unfortunately that's essentially all
we're getting more wind at a time we
need more than that
beta o'rourke who's running for office
again because he has no marketable
skills just stormed a press conference
to break texas officials he did this in
front of the families of some of
yesterday's victims
watch
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
this is totally predictable when you sir
you're out of line
sir you are out of line i'm sure you are
out of line please leave this auditorium
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come
oh come on that's saving lives that's
making this a better country beta work
sounds like one of those lunatics from
the westboro baptist church
gets off on making a scene but that's
essentially the answer we've gotten to
how to fix and prevent what happened in
ivaldi
please
anyone who talks like this should be
quiet for a minute and leave it to
everybody else to figure out why this is
happening and this is bigger than a
single mass shooting or even two of them
in 10 days there has been a huge
increase in violence in america on our
streets on public transportation in our
schools it's on a guess it's measurable
from january 1st to april 10th of this
year robberies in the new york transit
system are up more than 70 percent year
over year
felony assaults in the subway have
increased by 28 grand larceny according
to nypd is up by more than a hundred
percent those are all crimes of violence
and that's just underground
the same thing is happening on the
streets and if you don't know it
you just got back to the country after a
while according to abc news quote about
11 percent of violent crime in the city
of los angeles involved a homeless
person in 2018 13 in 2019 and 15 in 2020
if that was a graph it would look like
that keep in mind the homeless make up
about one percent of the total
population of los angeles but they're
involved in nearly a fifth of all
violent crimes in the city oh but ignore
it it's not happening
and yet everyone who lives here knows
that it is happening because the numbers
go up every year and if you have kids
you know what's happening because it's
the same story in the schools
the executive director of the national
association of school resource officers
mo kennedy told fox business that
schools are quote seeing more aggression
in terms of fights sometimes they're
shoving matches and sometimes they're
flat out assaults
it's more misbehavior thefts and those
kinds of things in schools
it didn't used to happen it's happening
now why it's not guns it's not the gun
lobby
more american families had guns at home
50 years ago than they do now according
to the rand corporation which studied
this 45 percent of american homes had a
gun in 1980. in 2016 that had dropped to
32 percent
so the problem is not that we're more
armed than we were the problem is that
people have changed young men have
changed they're more violent
why
that's the bipartisan conversation we
need to have now
and that conversation has been drowned
out by lunatic attention seekers who are
hoping to win the next election
but we don't need them now
never mind your election
there's something really wrong and we
can figure it out if we try
they're probably a lot of causes
the use of antidepressants in this
country is increasing dramatically
between 1991 and 2018 total ssri
consumption increased in the us by more
than 3 000 percent 3 000 percent
remember these are supposed to reduce
mental illness that's a real stat it was
published by the medical journal science
of the total environment
and it's not just this country in canada
state-funded anti-depressant
prescriptions for young people doubled
over the last decade
then during the lockdowns ssri
prescriptions increased even more
a pharmacy group called express scripts
reported that antidepressant
prescriptions went up by more than 20
during covid
according to the latest figures more
than 40 million americans are now taking
psychoactive drugs that's roughly 1 in
10.
so again the point of these drugs is to
make you healthier mentally
to reduce
suicide and violence and yet suicide
rates and rates of violence are spiking
we don't know that that's causation but
it's worth looking at
of course it's immoral to criticize big
pharma could we use an honest
conversation about this
yes
immediately clearly something's going on
watch three major medical associations
including the american academy of
pediatrics have together declared a
national state of emergency in
children's mental health caused by covid
parents report grief anxiety and
depression among children
citing school closures and forced
isolations as the primary culprits
suicide attempts among adolescents are
rising sharply most acutely among 12 to
17 year old girls by 51 since the start
of the pandemic
oh so the lockdowns dramatically
increase the incidence of mental illness
among young people and in 10 days we've
seen two mass shootings by mentally ill
young people could there be a connection
now that's not finger pointing it's not
to blame fouchy for yesterday's shooting
we're not that low we're not joe biden
but if people are becoming mentally ill
because they're disconnected from others
what can we do to connect them to others
and thereby reduce the incidence of
mental illness that's a real
conversation is there a more important
one
meanwhile more than a hundred thousand
people just died of ods
and the pandemic is responsible for some
of that watch
new numbers out today from the cdc show
how drug overdoses have surged during
the pandemic more than 107 000 americans
died of drug overdoses in 2021 that's
the highest annual death toll ever
recorded and a 15 increase from the year
before deaths involving fentanyl meth
and cocaine rose sharply
okay so people are doing more drugs
they're more unstable they're killing
themselves more often and in some rare
cases they're killing others now what
kind of mindset would it take to go
murder children in an elementary school
you are so disconnected from other human
beings that that seems okay to you what
could be adding to the feeling of
disconnection we have from one another
well
in 2020 adults in the united states
spend an average of eight hours every
day on digital media staring at a screen
the lockdowns made it worse they're not
the only cause but they definitely
exacerbated it that's a 20 jump from
2019.
one of the people who spent an awful lot
of time online during the pandemic was
the shooter in uvalde he reportedly
played a lot of call of duty instead of
going outside the shooter in buffalo
also spent a lot of time online as well
in fact he blamed the internet for
radicalizing him
i spent almost a year planning this
attack he wrote on april 26th oh how
time flies if i could go back maybe i'd
tell myself to get the f of 4chan and
the world truth videos and get an actual
life too late for that now
now that's not an argument for censoring
those or any other sites it's an
argument for experiencing real life
nature other people animals anything but
a screen staring at a screen all day
puts you into your own world and in some
small number of cases it drives you
insane it makes you mentally ill and
violent that's very obvious that's one
of the reasons that people in silicon
valley to tech executives don't their
own kids lose themselves in their stupid
ipads
back in september of 2013 after a mass
shooting at the washington navy yard the
late charles krauthammer identified the
problem
we have a lot of mentally ill people
and we need to stop ignoring them
obviously we've ignored that warning so
here it is again
he needed help
30 years ago the cops would have brought
him to a psychiatric emergency room he
probably would have gotten
antipsychotics and he probably would
have been hospitalized for a couple of
weeks
that's the way it was done in the 70s
when
when i practiced psychiatry but today
that doesn't happen the cops left he was
left on his own he was a man who
shouldn't have been on his own he should
have had the state looking after him and
he ended up killing people in a way
that's look you want to respect the
civil liberties of everybody but there
is a point in which if you don't take
control of people who are clearly
out of touch with reality you are
damaging them exposing them and of
course tragically exposing a lot of
innocents around them
yeah
exactly
this stuff is complicated the human mind
is complicated and if the environment
changes so does the mind people can't go
outside or talk to other people or spend
eight hours a day staring at a screen
if they're on brain changing chemicals
in
huge numbers tens of millions of people
you think that has an effect
yeah
what effect well is anyone studying what
murderers not just mass murderers but
all murderers have in common
apparently not it would be nice to know
instead of telling us about the gun
lobby
please no one believes that and why by
the way is the answer to mass shootings
always universal gun confiscation should
we be focused on the people who did it
on the dangerous people
it's like forcing the entire population
into drug rehab in response to fentanyl
crisis probably better to focus on the
addicts why do they get addicted how can
we help them let's be serious about this
children died it's real stop with the
talking points be honest
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight